The new Game of Thrones prequel show has begun
with House of the Dragon Episode 1.
It has a tournament, a horrific childbirth,
a secret prophecy, lots of dragons, and Matt
Smith’s butt.
So what does it all mean, and how does the
show compare to the book?
This video has no spoilers beyond Episode
1 and the original Game of Thrones show.
The episode’s called The Heirs of the Dragon,
because that’s the name of the chapter in
the book the show’s based on, Fire & Blood.
The big question this episode is succession
– who will inherit the Throne?
It starts with a flashback to the Council
at Harrenhal in the year 101.
This is two hundred years before Game of Thrones,
and Daenerys and Jon Snow.
And it’s one hundred years after Aegon Targaryen
conquered Westeros and started the Targaryen
dynasty.
At this time, the king is Jaehaerys Targaryen
– he was the fourth king of Westeros, and
he’s seen as one of the best kings ever.
His reign was peaceful and prosperous, he
reformed laws, and built roads.
But Jaehaerys had bad relationships with some
of the women in his life – the book says
“He was better with roads than with daughters”.
And Jaehaerys had a messy succession, deciding
who would rule Westeros after him.
Cause originally Jaehaerys’ heir was his
eldest son Aemon – but Aemon got killed.
So then Jaehaerys said his second son Baelon
was his heir – even though Aemon had a daughter
called Rhaenys – and some people said Rhaenys
or her children should inherit the Throne.
But Jaehaerys chose Baelon, and then Baelon
died of a.. sore tummy.
So then Jaehaerys was like shit, now what
– and he held this big council to choose
the new heir to the Throne.
They held the council at Harrenhal because
it’s the biggest castle in Westeros.
It’s also mostly ruined because Aegon the
Conqueror burned it with his dragon Balerion
a hundred years ago.
We see Arya at Harrenhal in Game of Thrones
Season 2.
So the lords are here to choose an heir, and
the main candidates are Rhaenys Targaryen,
daughter of Aemon, and Viserys Targaryen,
son of Baelon.
In the book, Rhaenys’ son Laenor is a more
popular candidate than Rhaenys, because he’s
male, and the lords prefer male rulers to
women.
Laenor’s claim is supported by his father,
Corlys Velaryon, who’s very rich and influential.
And there are some other candidates – the
book mentions Jaehaerys’ son Vaegon, but
he’s a.. nerd who.. no one likes, and is
a maester sworn to the Citadel.
They also mention Jaehaerys’ daughter Saera,
but she’s busy running a brothel in the
east.
One of Saera’s bastard sons turns up, with
an elephant, but the lords aren’t impressed.
They consider Laenor, and Rhaenys, but in
the end they choose Viserys to be the next
king, because he’s an adult male who inherits
through the male line.
Many lords see this as an “iron precedent”
the Throne will always be inherited by men
not women – to the great frustration of
Rhaenys and her family.
The books say that Viserys won this vote by
twenty to one, though the maesters who counted
the votes never revealed the numbers – so
some fans speculate that the maesters rigged
the vote to choose the heir they wanted.
Some characters in the books say that the
maesters have a conspiracy against dragons.
And while Laenor has the dragon Seasmoke,
and Rhaenys rides the dragon Meleys, Viserys
doesn’t ride a dragon, because his dragon
Balerion died.
So maybe the maesters rigged the vote for
Viserys because they preferred a king who
didn’t have a dragon – but.. that’s
just a theory.
Point is, Viserys becomes heir to the Throne.
And the episode continues about ten years
later.
Viserys is now king.
And we see his daughter, Princess Rhaenyra,
flying her dragon Syrax.
She parks her dragon at the Dragonpit, which
is like a big stable where the dragons live.
We see the Dragonpit in Game of Thrones two
hundred years later, when it’s become a
ruin.
The Dragonpit is guarded by the Dragonkeepers.
The books describe them as “proud warriors”,
in gleaming scaled armor”.
But in Hot D, they’re a “monk-like order”
in grimy robes – maybe scooping dragon poop
is part of their job.
This one seems to have a dragonglass dagger,
which is interesting – dragonglass is a
special volcanic material that can kill white
walkers.
The Dragonkeepers command dragons in the Valyrian
language, which came from Valyria, the ancient
lost empire of the original dragonlords.
Rhaenyra’s dragon Syrax is named after a
Valyrian goddess.
So Rhaenyra puts her dragon in day care, and
we meet Harrold Westerling.
He’s a member of the Kingsguard, and the
sworn protector of Princess Rhaenyra.
The Targaryen royal family live in the Red
Keep, and we see the Keep full of lords and
courtiers in rich and colourful clothing – this
is the political centre of the realm in a
time of prosperity and splendour.
This courtyard is the place where Cersei Lannister
paints a map of Westeros, two hundred years
later.
Rhaenyra visits her mother, Aemma Arryn, the
wife and queen of King Viserys.
Aemma’s mother was a Targaryen, so she and
Viserys are also cousins.
Aemma doesn’t like it when Rhaenyra goes
flying, like in Game of Thrones when Catelyn
doesn’t like it when Bran goes climbing.
Aemma is pregnant, and she tells Rhaenyra
it’s the duty of a lady to make babies for
the realm.
But Rhaenyra says she’d rather be a knight
and ride in battle.
It’s like in Game of Thrones, when Arya
doesn’t want to marry and have kids.
So while Aemma seems resigned to her role
in the patriarchy, Rhaenyra dreams of a different
life.
Rhaenyra serves as cupbearer on King Viserys’
small council.
His councillors are Otto Hightower, Hand of
the King.
Lyonel Strong, master of laws.
Mellos, the Grand Maester.
Lyman Beesbury, master of coin.
And Corlys Velaryon, master of ships.
>Though at this point in the book, Corlys
had quit the council because he was angry
about his wife Rhaenys and son Laenor not
getting the Throne at the Harrenhal council.
Each councillor has a round stone to represent
their presence.
We also see Ryam Redwyne, the Commander of
the Kingsguard.
Ryam has been on the Kingsguard for some fifty
years, and he’s a legendary knight.
At one point, King Jaehaerys made Ryam the
Hand of the King – but Ryam was a terrible
Hand, so Jaehaerys had fire him – turns
out that being a good knight doesn’t make
you a good politician.
Corlys warns the council about the Triarchy.
The Triarchy is an alliance of the eastern
cities of Tyrosh, Myr and Lys.
They’ve started attacking pirates on the
Stepstones, these little islands between Westeros
and Essos.
And Corlys is worried that if the Triarchy
take control of the Stepstones, they could
disrupt trade up the narrow sea.
Corlys’ family the Velaryons are based on
Driftmark in the narrow sea, and they make
their money off this trade.
So, like all good prequels, this show might
start with a trade dispute.
But the other councillors don’t care about
the Stepstones, and they discuss the upcoming
tournament and Queen Aemma’s pregnancy.
We see Viserys eating an egg, which is a symbol
of fertility and birth.
Though the way Viserys cracks the egg open
is an omen of how Aemma’s pregnancy ends.
Rhaenyra sees her uncle, Prince Daemon.
Daemon sits on the Throne, which he’s not
meant to do, showing his desire for power
and willingness to break rules.
Daemon and Rhaenyra speak in Valyrian, and
he gives her a necklace of Valyrian steel
– the special magic steel that was made
in old Valyria.
Just like Daemon has a sword of Valyrian steel,
called Dark Sister.
Apparently, Daemon’s helmet is also made
of Valyrian steel.
So the Targaryens in this time celebrate their
Valyrian ancestry – despite the fact that
the Valyrians were pretty evil – their empire
killed and enslaved thousands of people – yet
the Targaryens see them as role models.
Rhaenyra hangs out with her friend Alicent
Hightower.
Alicent wants to study like a proper lady,
but Rhaenyra wants adventure and.. cake.
Alicent and Rhaenyra are kinda like ladylike
Sansa and rebellious Arya – except instead
of being rivals, Alicent and Rhaenyra are
close friends.
They talk about Nymeria, a warrior queen from
the east who lived a thousand years ago.
Nymeria led her people on a great migration
and found a new homeland in Dorne – Nymeria
left a legacy in Dorne of female power and
equality.
>HBO has worked on a potential spin-off show
about Nymeria.
Despite Rhaenyra’s rebellious attitude,
she does know all about Nymeria – showing
that she’s smart, and she’s aware of a
great female leader.
Which again is like Arya – Arya named her
direwolf after Nymeria.
We see a weirwood tree in the Red Keep.
Weirwoods, with their red leaves and carved
faces, are the sacred trees of the old gods,
the magic power than Bran connects to in Game
of Thrones.
In the books, there is no weirwood in the
Red Keep – most weirwoods were destroyed
in the south when the new religion of the
Seven took over.
So this is an interesting change – will
the magic of the old gods have a role in this
story?
King Viserys has cuts on his body that he
got from sitting the Iron Throne.
The Throne is made of sharp swords making
it impossible to sit on comfortably – and
Aegon the Conqueror made it that way deliberately
– this dangerous throne symbolises that
kings must use power carefully and wisely,
or else their power will destroy them.
When a king is cut by the Iron Throne, that
hints that the king isn’t handling power
well.
The Mad King Aerys the Second, the father
of Daenerys, cuts himself on the Throne so
often that he’s called King Scab.
King Maegor the Cruel died on the Throne,
and some say he was killed by the Throne.
As though the Throne rejects unworthy kings.
So it’s very ominous that the Throne cuts
Viserys, and that the wound is not healing.
Viserys visits his pregnant wife Aemma.
Aemma jokes that she might hatch a dragon,
which is interesting, because several Targaryens
in the books give birth to deformed babies
with dragon-like features.
Daenerys gives birth to a stillborn that is
“scaled like a lizard”, with leathery
wings.
The reason for this might be that the Targaryens
have the blood of the dragon – their Valyrian
ancestors claimed that they were literally
descended from dragons, with like dragon DNA,
which is probably what allows them to control
dragons.
Aemma is having a bad time with her pregnancy.
She’s already had multiple stillbirths and
miscarriages.
The book says Aemma and Viserys first had
sex when she was just thirteen, and some maesters
say she got pregnant too young, and this damaged
her health.
But Viserys keeps wanting more kids cause
he wants a son to inherit his Throne.
Viserys is convinced that their unborn child
is male, because he had a dream of a son,
and Targaryens do have prophetic dreams of
the future.
The whole political stability of Westeros
depends on queens producing male heirs, so
Aemma is reluctantly dragged along with her
husband’s dream – though she says she
can’t do this again.
Viserys’ brother, Daemon, is the Commander
of the gold cloaks, the City Watch of King’s
Landing.
And he leads a brutal, violent crackdown on..
alleged criminals in the city.
We see Daemon personally kill a murderer.
The book says that Daemon delights in mutilating
criminals, cutting off hands and noses and
cocks – so this is not just about.. law
enforcement, it’s about Viserys enjoying
violence, spreading fear, and asserting his
power.
The gold cloaks are like his personal loyal
army, two thousand strong, in the heart of
the realm.
Otto Hightower, is angry about this bloodbath.
He wants to reduce Daemon’s power, and prevent
him getting the Throne.
Daemon responds like a smirking sulky teenager,
who’s acting out for attention.
He misbehaves because he wants his brother
Viserys to notice him and accept him.
Daemon has sex with his lover, Mysaria, but
Daemon can’t climax – he feels unsatisfied,
with pent up feelings that he can’t seem
to let out.
It’s like the only ways Daemon knows how
to feel better is through sex and violence,
and if that doesn’t work for him, what will?
Mysaria suggests that Daemon have sex with
a silver-haired maiden – which is interesting
because Daemon’s niece Rhaenyra is a silver-haired
maiden, who he seemed pretty close with earlier.
Daemon is stressed because if Aemma gives
birth to a son, that son will replace Daemon
as heir to the Throne.
Viserys holds a big tournament to celebrate
the coming birth of his child.
There’s jousting, and fighting, and there’s
politics.
Lord Boremund Baratheon competes – he’s
an ancestor of Robert, Stannis and Renly Baratheon.
Boremund is also the uncle of Rhaenys Targaryen,
and at the Harrenhal council he supported
Rhaenys and Laenor in their claim for the
Throne.
So now, Boremund calls Rhaenys “The Queen
Who Never Was”.
It’s a little treasonous to publicly undermine
King Viserys by bringing up Rhaenys’ claim,
but Viserys is chill and he allows the light
treason.
Prince Daemon joins the tourney, and he chooses
to joust against Gwayne Hightower, the son
of Otto Hightower, specifically to piss off
Otto.
He also requests the favour of Otto’s daughter
Alicent.
So Daemon really is a master of annoying Otto.
Some of the knights start killing each other
on the tourney grounds, which you’re not
meant to do, but it does happen – like in
Game of Thrones, when the Mountain attacks
Loras and the Hound.
Rhaenys says these knights are “green as
summer grass” – they’re young, dumb
and full of cum, and have never experienced
real war, or hard times.
It’s similar to a bit in the books, when
Catelyn says that winter is coming for these
knights of summer.
This is about loss of innocence, disillusionment,
the inevitable end of good times.
The surprise favourite of the tournament is
Criston Cole.
Criston isn’t from some rich and famous
family.
He’s the son of a steward, and in Hot D
he’s Dornish – which is interesting, because
in this time period, Dorne has not yet been
conquered by the Targaryens.
It’s still an independent kingdom with its
own laws and culture.
So Criston is an outsider and an underdog,
and he has a lot to gain by proving himself
with his fighting skills.
Criston defeats the famous Prince Daemon in
jousting and combat – partly by attacking
Daemon while he wasn’t looking.
Though to be fair, Daemon also played dirty
by tripping Gwayne Hightower horse’s with
his lance – everyone’s breaking the rules
here.
But Criston wins, and he clearly makes an
impression on Rhaenyra and Alicent.
Meanwhile, Queen Aemma’s childbirth goes
wrong.
Mellos says that Aemma’s gonna die, and
the only way to save the baby is to cut it
out of her, like a medieval c-section, which
will kill Aemma.
Viserys is horrified, but he wants his male
heir, so he agrees to cut up his wife open
to save his child.
They..
don’t ask Aemma what she wants.
So they start the bloody procedure, and it’s
intercut with knights fighting at the tourney
– the battlefield of men and the birthing
bed of women as two sides in an endless violent
cycle of death and life.
Aemma dies, and Viserys gets his baby son,
and names him Baelon, but then Baelon dies
too, from birth complications maybe.
So at the funeral, the baby Baelon is cremated
along with Queen Aemma.
In the books, Aemma just dies in childbirth,
it doesn’t mention a c-section.
But that does happen to a different character
in the book, Alyssa Velaryon.
Alyssa was the mother of King Jaehaerys, and
of Boremund Baratheon by her second husband,
Rogar.
Rogar kept getting Alyssa pregnant even though
she was too old and it was dangerous for her.
Her next childbirth went bad, and like Viserys,
Rogar chose to cut his wife open to save the
baby, because he wanted a son.
Alyssa’s daughter Rhaena was furious at
Rogar for this.
She blamed him for Alyssa’s death because
he got her pregnant when it was dangerous
for her, and she’s angry that he valued
his wife’s life less than he valued making
a son.
We can see a hint of that anger on Rhaenyra’s
face, when she looks at Viserys and then says
dracarys – fire.
Cause this episode highlights how much Rhaenyra
cares for her mother, and how frustrated she
is that Viserys seems to care more about getting
a son than he cares about his wife and daughter.
Rhaenyra sees Aemma dead because of Viserys’
dream, and she resents being pushed into the
same gender role that killed her mother.
After the funeral, the council talks succession.
It’s very dangerous when there’s no clear
heir to the Throne, because competing claims
often lead to war.
Precedent says Viserys’ brother Daemon is
next in line, but most folks don’t want
the violent Daemon on the Throne.
Otto suggests Rhaenyra, and Corlys suggests
Rhaenys, but Lyonel argues there’s never
been a female ruler.
So Viserys storms off, leaving the future
of the realm uncertain.
Otto decides to act.
He tells his daughter Alicent to put on her
mother’s dress and go “comfort” the
newly single King Viserys in his bedchamber.
Otto is similar to Tywin Lannister in Game
of Thrones – being Hand, writing letters,
using his children for his political ambitions.
Alicent finds Viserys working on a model city,
using a nerdy hobby to cope with his grief.
The city looks similar to Dragonstone, but
bigger – it might represent old Valyria.
Or maybe Viserys is imagining a grand expansion
to the Dragonstone castle.
There was once another Targaryen king who
dreamed of a white city – the Mad King Aerys.
Some fans have also noticed that the model
city looks like the opening sequence to Game
of Thrones.
Meanwhile, Daemon has his own way of coping
with emotions – he drinks alone, fully clothed,
in the middle of an orgy he set up for his
gold cloaks.
Mysaria prompts him to speak, and Daemon gives
a toast to Viserys’ dead baby – calling
him the “heir for a day”, celebrating
that with Baelon’s death, Daemon remains
heir to the Throne.
Otto tells Viserys this, so Viserys confronts
Daemon, turning his grief for his wife and
child into fury at his brother.
Daemon gets angry back, calls Viserys weak.
So Viserys finally decides to disinherit Daemon,
and sends him away to the Vale.
It’s tragic that these two brothers, who
love each other, fight when they so need each
others’ support.
Immediately after, Viserys again cuts himself
on the Throne – another dark omen.
So Viserys and Daemon are separated, and that
was probably Otto’s plan, this is why he
told Viserys about Daemon’s toast.
Daemon says that Otto is an ambitious scheming
cunt, and Otto himself said that all men want
“absolute power”.
At the same time that Otto pushes Daemon away,
he moves his daughter Alicent closer to the
king.
Viserys decides to make his daughter Rhaenyra
heir to the Throne.
He says he was wrong to focus on an unborn
son when Rhaenyra has the potential to be
a great ruler.
>Though Viserys knows that the Throne is a
terrible responsibility.
He knows the danger of dragons and their power
– he talks about Valyria, how their power
and pride led to their downfall.
>Though the exact cause of the Doom of Valyria
is a mystery.
And Viserys tells Rhaenyra a big secret.
So, a hundred years ago, Aegon Targaryen,
the Conqueror, took over Westeros and started
the line of Targaryen kings.
Viserys says that part of why Aegon conquered
Westeros is because he had a dream of a winter
from the north that would destroy humanity
– Aegon had a dream of the white walkers.
Aegon believed that a Targaryen king must
unite the realm to save the world from the
walkers, and that’s why he conquered Westeros.
This dream of Aegon’s isn’t in the books.
But it was author George Martin’s idea to
add this to the show, and in the books there
are other Targaryens who know about a prophecy
to save the world – Aemon, Jaehaerys the
Second, probably Bloodraven.
And Rhaegar Targaryen, the brother of Daenerys
and the father of Jon Snow.
The books say that when Rhaegar was young,
he found something in some scrolls that convinced
him to be a warrior.
Maybe Rhaegar discovered Aegon’s white walker
dream.
Daenerys has a vision of Rhaegar, where Rhaegar
mentions “the song of ice and fire”.
And Viserys says that Aegon’s dream is called
“The Song of Ice and Fire”.
This prophecy is probably why Rhaegar ran
off with Lyanna and had Jon Snow – he musta
believed that his son would stop the white
walkers, finally fulfilling Aegon’s dream
of the Targaryens saving the world.
Of course, we know this dream doesn’t exactly
come true.
In Game of Thrones Season 8, the white walkers
are not defeated by a Targaryen or by a united
Westeros – Arya Stark kills the white walkers,
and at the time, Westeros is divided, with
Cersei Lannister on the Throne.
So maybe this dream was misinterpreted.
Aegon was right about the white walkers – but
he was wrong to think that his family would
be the saviours.
It’s like how Viserys misinterprets his
dream about his heir.
He was right that there’d be thundering
hooves and splintering shields, and his heir
on the Throne.
But he was wrong to assume that his heir was
a son.
In the books, prophecies and dreams are often
misinterpreted due to characters’ ambition
and biases, often leading to their downfall.
As Marwyn says, “Prophecy will bite your
prick off every time”.
Viserys wears this Valyrian steel dagger.
This is the same dagger that Arya uses to
kill the Night King in Game of Thrones.
The same dagger she uses to kill Littlefinger.
The same dagger in this book Sam found.
The same dagger that an assassin used against
Catelyn, and that Littlefinger lied about
to start the whole war in GOT Season 1.
So is this special dagger part of the prophecy?
Or is it just some.. cosmic coincidence that
this is the knife that saves the world?
[This knife isn’t super important in the
books].
The showrunners say they included this prophecy
and this knife to raise the stakes in Hot
D, and to connect it with the conflict in
Game of Thrones.
Viserys tells Rhaenyra to promise him to keep
this secret dream.
Just like Ned Stark promises Lyanna to keep
the secret of Jon Snow.
There’s a big ceremony where the lords of
the realm swear loyalty to Rhaenyra, and promise
to support her claim to the Throne when Viserys
dies.
She is set to become the first female ruler
of Westeros.
But this moment isn’t all.. triumphant – it
feels dangerous.
Daemon is angry that he’s been replaced.
Rhaenys and her family have been snubbed again.
Otto is plotting.
Some of these lords don’t look happy about
a female heir, this does go against the precedent
of the Harrenhal Council.
And Rhaenyra never wanted any of this, all
she wanted was to fly and have fun and eat
cake.
But now she not only has to rule the continent,
she has to save it from the frosty apocalypse
cause her great-great-great-grandpa had a
dream.
All the power and dreams of House Targaryen
weigh upon her, and the theme of this episode
is that power and dreams are dangerous.
House of the Dragon is based on the book Fire
& Blood – Season 1 covers Chapter 12, Heirs
of the Dragon.
There’s also a shorter summary of the story
of Hot D in the book The World of Ice and
Fire, starting in the Viserys chapter.
So if you want to know the full story of House
of the Dragon, from beginning to end, with
all the spoilers, you can get either of these
on audiobook for free right now at audible.com/asx.
Sign up for a Premium Plus trial membership,
and you get an audiobook to keep, even if
you cancel the trial.
You can get any Game of Thrones book, or Lord
of the Rings, or Dune.
Membership also includes unlimited access
to thousands of audiobooks and shows in the
Audible Plus Catalog.
Sign up at audible.com/asx, or text asx to
500-500.
Thanks for watching.
We’re doing a Hot D livestream every Sunday
at about 10:15pm Eastern time, and doing an
Explained video like this each week.
So like and subscribe, press the bell, follow
the Twitter.
Thank you the supporters on Patreon, including
LANCE, Duncan Brookover, Rachel Krengel, The
Bastard Daughter, Courtney Brdlik, Pedro Coelho,
and mattt.
Cheers.